dan how many screenplays would you say
over the course of your lifetime you've
read I probably over a thousand I'm not
one of those people who's like I've read
five or six thousands dan of the
numerous scripts that you've read how
many would you say went on to become
films very few it's very rare that they
do it's hard for a script to get
optioned or sold and then it's even
harder for it to get produced so it's
very rare and that's why I always say
your script has to be great it can't
just be good it has to be great that's
why I titled my first book how to write
a great screenplay with great in caps
because working as a reader and now as a
writing coach something really has to
blow me away and because it's so tough
for it to rise up the ladder and become
an option script a sold script a
produced script so you really have to
come in with something with a unique
voice with a unique approach to a
commercially successful genre it's
really tough so I can't really put my
finger on how many became produced of
scripts that I read but it's few and far
between so going back to when you were
you got a BFA at NYU yeah you were doing
this like script reading and all that
from that time when you went to NYU to
the beginning stages of the script
reading job were you aware of how tough
it was or at that time it was just like
you thought that if something was really
good and it was a first time writer the
doors were open I was probably a bit
more naive I probably thought that more
things rose up the ladder and got bought
and greenlit and produced but after a
while I realized well first things first
nine out of ten scripts I would pass on
I would reject so I got the sense right
away that even though this was you know
on the professional level and these
scripts were coming from agents and
managers and producers some had major
stars attached but the material just
wasn't there
just wasn't great and so I would pass on
most things 9 out of 10 things so what
was great was as a reader I was always
looking for that thing to say yes to not
to say no to because it was so
exhilarating when I finally found that
one out of 10 or one out of 20 scripts
that month that really blew me away and
really brought it and excited me and I
was happy to give it a consider or
recommend on the coverage report was it
that black or white was it either a yay
or a nay or was there sometimes a middle
ground where yes but this needs to be
tightened up yeah there's something
called consider with reservations which
is this could be a great movie for my
employer but there's reservations about
it it would be really expensive there's
not a kind of star role in it it's too
long so it need to be cut down but we're
considering it that reader is
considering it because it's great
writing you know and now what's good
about the consider with reservations or
just the consider level evaluation which
because there's passed consider
recommend recommend is really high
recommend is like this is not only great
material but this is ready and perfect
for my employer so this particular
studio this is right in their wheelhouse
it's right in the budget range so I
fully recommend that consider is a
really good grade and any writer should
be excited to get a consider and what it
means is even if that particular piece
of material isn't right for that
production company or that studio the
writer is a good writer and they may
want to work with this writer on another
project so they may want to bring them
in for a meeting see if there's someone
they could work with and then maybe give
them an assignment you know like a
rewrite assignment excellent how often
have you seen an unknown writer be a
recommend come in and they greenlight it
and it actually happens how often does
that happen
well that's very rare I just in general
I probably only gave a handful of rec
in eight nine years I mean literally
like five or six in each case I
personally didn't know the writer like
one case there was a book by I didn't
know his name at the time I was reading
it but it turns out he was a pretty
well-known writer who written he'd also
written a famous movie and he'd written
some books but at the time he was an
unknown to me because I didn't recognize
his name and so the few times I've had
the recommend they haven't been from
produced named writers they were
basically from unknowns you know they
were writers that I didn't recognize
their names interesting and you found
something about their voice unique yeah
they had a great voice
they had material that was in the
wheelhouse of the studio I was working
for so was in that genre it was in that
budget range it was the kind of thing
they were look they were looking for
when I was working for Miramax which was
headed by Harvey Weinstein at the time
the Weinstein brothers it was known that
Harvey liked to shoot in Italy so any
material that was set in Italy was to be
considered hire you know was to be given
more attention and so in one case I
actually had a development executive
give me a book and say this is set in
Italy Harvey loves Italy he's looking
for another thing to shoot in Italy he
just shot gangs in New York with
Scorsese there and so I really want you
to give this a good evaluation and
hopefully you'll like it and I actually
asked her I'm like do you want me to
just give it a consider you know even if
it sucks you know I help you out here
and she's like no no no I want you to
give us your honest opinion and I read
it and it wasn't good enough and so I
passed on it and I don't know what
happened after that but she probably
wasn't happy with me it's better that's
about it yeah it's all about the
material so and I just didn't think the
material was there so as a reader you
don't know very much about this writer
and is that right
I'm assuming it's yeah you don't know
anything really that's good unless you
recognize the name so yeah the reader
gets no information going in they may
see a cover letter they may see an email
history maybe but not always so if they
happen to see an email history they may
know a little bit about the off you know
this is what the agent has written back
and forth
with the development executive before
they actually send the PDF so the reader
may see that but they probably won't
because it's all about the material is
this material strong enough you know if
it's coming from Aaron Sorkin you may
give a little bit more weight to that
because Aaron Sorkin can get a film made
he can write a greenlit movie but you're
still evaluating on the writing so if
Aaron Sorkin has written something
that's not right for your company or
just isn't at the level of quality that
would get a recommend or consider if
that readers being honest they're gonna
pass on it yeah I'm just wondering how
much of your own personal bias you know
it we've seen someone's picture you
might like them more and then like their
script more you know yeah or if you know
their backstory and then maybe but you
shouldn't do that you shouldn't have any
bias and in my experience I almost never
knew the backstory of a particular piece
of material
you